were you aware at the time that in
addition to making fake bombs the FBI
had been recruiting mr. Fayyad for 18
months
no ma'am that he has no history of
violence no history of terrorist
affiliations who doesn't know that
there's no evidence indicating he's ever
judged interest in terrorism included by
this team of agents no ma'am
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer today we're covering a show
called for the people I don't know
anything about this show but it was
highly requested by you out there so
keep those recommendations coming I'm
always looking for new portrayal of
lawyers and courtrooms in the media as
always be sure to comment in the form of
an objection without either sustain or
overrule and while you're there let me
know what movie or TV show I should do
next
and of course stick around until the end
of this video where I give the first
episode of for the people a grade for
legal realism so without further ado
let's dig into the first episode of for
the people all right New York it's
always New York for some reason
[Music]
ah the famous New York Supreme Court oh
that's it that's a different courthouse
oh that is the Riverside California
courthouse I know that courthouse very
well both New York one and the
California one there are two great
courts in America the Supreme Court and
the one you're sitting in right now
this is a United States District Court
for the Southern District of New York
the oldest most prestigious
highest-profile trial court in America I
don't know if the SDN why is the oldest
US Court I would think that it was
created at the same time as the other
district courts but there's no doubt
that the Southern District of New York
is one of the most high-profile federal
courts in the United States there is a
ton of high-profile litigation that goes
on in the Southern District of New York
because that is where in New York City
is so there are a lot of high-profile
cases there so it is not an exaggeration
to say that it is one of the most
prestigious places to be an assistant US
attorney or a federal public defender
this is the court that heard claims over
the sinking of the Titanic this is the
court that heard the case against the
Rosenbergs Aaron Burr was a lawyer in
this Court
you want to claim Aaron Burr the cases
are hard stakes are high the lawyers on
the other side of better than you and
the judges are smarter than you some of
you won't succeed some of you
are not worthy but for those of you who
are your time here will be the highlight
of your career all right that's not a
crazy speech to be given by a judge at a
swearing-in ceremony that's I can
imagine that actually happening in real
life welcome to the mother court
and they're walking out of the Supreme
Court the state court I think it's funny
so interestingly this takes place in
federal court not state court the way
that law and order does law and order
takes place entirely within the state
court but the federal courts exist for
two reasons number one there are federal
laws as you may know there are two types
of law in the United States there are
those that are created by the state
governments and there are the laws that
are created by the federal government
sometimes there's overlap sometimes
there isn't but if you have a case that
deals specifically with a federal law
and federal jurisdiction you're going to
be litigating your case in the federal
courts and then additionally especially
if you're on the civil side you'll deal
with what's called diversity
jurisdiction where if you have
defendants who are citizens of different
states the federal courts were designed
to handle litigation amongst different
states and among citizens of different
states to make sure that everyone gets a
fair shake but this looks like it's
going to be a criminal show because
we're dealing with the federal
prosecutors and the federal public
defenders so that leads me to believe
that this show is probably dealing
exclusively with federal criminal law as
opposed to civil law good morning
everyone I'm Jill Carlin I'm the federal
public defender inside these envelopes
is your first case and let me warn you
you're not gonna win you're up against
the United States government and the
government almost always wins because
they have all the power some truth to it
so the advice that this head public
defender is giving them while a little
cynical is probably pretty accurate
you're probably not going to take a lot
of these things to trial you're probably
not going to go to the mat on a lot of
these cases but you're going to plead
you're going to give these people the
best defense you possibly can even if
that results in guilty pleas down the
line what's duty the attorney on duty
picks up the new cases that go
do you need someone today yes but you
have to have some experience to be on
duty sander I have experience you have
experienced lurking on the Supreme Court
which is great experience from being a
justice that's free doesn't have
anything to do with this job I'll put
you under you when you're ready I'm
ready yes that is accurate if you clerk
for the Supreme Court that is the most
prestigious thing you could possibly do
it's a huge star in your record but it
doesn't mean you necessarily have
on-the-ground experience although some
people do have experience before they
clerk for the Supreme Court but it would
not be a shonda rhimes legal TV show if
there wasn't someone that clerked for
the Supreme Court shows up in all of her
shows for some reason why would I give
you his case because a farm animal could
win this case in that case actually
matters and if it matters you should
give it to me and I was clerking on the
Supreme Court another Supreme Court
Clerk Wow
is that true Leonard doesn't think
you're ready for this case oh he's right
neither one of us is ready for a case
like this but I'm at least humble enough
to recognize it and I'll work that much
harder because of it
[Music]
never been a fan of humility that's so
ridiculous
also where are their supervising
attorneys you're not gonna handle a
terrorism case on your first day as an
AUSA that's ridiculous
do a good job on your new case and
you'll get recognized because you're
good and d-7 do things the right way
which is what matters in the long run
okay okay now I have to go because I
have my first appearance as an attorney
in the Southern District of New York
first appearance is your first day
what's the charge
18 USC 23 32 83 you pick this up on duty
yes I've dated be on duty 23 32 83 isn't
it useful weapon of mass destruction
against any property that has only store
used by the United States or by any
department or agency of the United
States I know no you don't that's
ridiculous that anyone would have
encyclopedic knowledge of the entire US
code just memorize like that the entire
US code is bigger than all of those
books put together and it is ridiculous
for to expect that anyone would have the
Code section memorized even just the
criminal law sections memorizes
preposterous Your Honor as alleged in
the complaint Madeline Locarno was an
administrative assistant at olaria
pharmaceuticals and illegally traded on
inside information regarding a merger
between ilaria and biotech excuse me
your honor but the complaint actually
does not allege that it alleges that
Miss Locarno passed on information to
her ex-husband who executed the trades
facts which we deny what was the value
of the trades nine thousand three
hundred twenty-five dollars and fifty
four cents your honor
nine thousand dollars
this is what Roger Gunn is prioritizing
in the US Attorney's Office nowadays so
unlike most shows I've seen the people
were actually arguing with the judge
behind Council table which is generally
where you're going to be arguing you're
not gonna be wandering inside of the
well like you see on TV so that kind of
colloquy is probably something you would
see in real life and a judge is likely
to get upset about a matter that is
taking up the government's time over
just $9,000 that's a very small case so
I would expect the judge to be annoyed
by that if you're offering a deal like
that in a case like this there must be
something wrong with the evidence maybe
but if you want to find out you're gonna
have to reject the offer and if you
reject the offer you're going to trial
and if you go to lose also maybe I can
give you to someone else no just because
you reject a plea deal early on in the
case doesn't mean that that plea deal
will no longer be available throughout
the rest of the case this particular
case is probably gonna take a year or
two before it even gets to trial there
will be months if not years of
litigation and it would not be insane to
reject the first plea deal especially
when you haven't even talked to your
client yet so she's not really in a
position to know whether the plea deal
is good or bad at this point so of
course if there's a choice she's going
to have to reject it and by the way
she's gonna have to talk to her client
about whether to accept or reject the
plea deal - so I understand the cynicism
from the head PD here that you're just
trying to plead these things down but
you can't do that on your first day when
you don't know any of the facts in this
situation are you okay I'm gonna do this
[Music]
you know how we've always that is a
really nice apartment in New York you
rejected a plea deal without talking to
me you said talk to my client I talked
to my client
well you didn't talk to me and that was
a mistake and you can't afford to make
mistakes like that
on a job like this yeah do you really
need to talk to your supervising
attorney there that's that's a big deal
right there well Kate here's the problem
for you my client and let's keep it
simple and tell him Adam Dyle couldn't
have committed the alleged fraud because
as you probably have tab there in one of
your binders fraud requires an intent to
deceive Adam didn't argue it because he
actually believes all this is real crazy
possibly but the upshot is no intent no
crime he is technically right I assume
that the crime of fraud is probably
similar to the civil requirements for
fraud which do require an intent to
deceive or a knowing falsity of the
representations that one makes that
being said that is a very very difficult
argument to make especially given that
there will be other circumstantial
evidence like the fact that he took all
of the money from the people that he
defrauded and used it for his own
purposes you don't have to necessarily
bring a psychologist in you can just say
that well he took the money from these
people that he defrauded and therefore
that shows that he had the required
mental state and that's probably going
to carry the day good luck in court man
now I've got a full promo for your own
tabs or of my discovery guide request
jailhouse recordings nice that is a
hundred percent accurate when you make a
phone call in jail unless it's to your
lawyer
that is definitely discoverable in fact
most jails have a warning that says your
phone call will be recorded so you don't
have a reasonable expectation of privacy
and you should be on notice that your
phone calls are going to be recorded and
they can be used against you this is a
little bit dramatic but definitely could
happen I just don't understand why we're
prosecuting a case like this against a
secretary for a $9,000 trade well that
is a problem that you don't understand
that so let me spell it out for you
you're prosecuting the case because I
told you to I told you to prosecute the
case because that secretary broke the
law every now and then regular order
people need to be reminded that there's
serious consequences to breaking the law
whatever the law insider trading yeah
absolutely stop signs people start doing
whatever the hell they feel like our
whole system breaks down cars crash
markets crash people get hurt yeah and
it'll piss off the judge but he's
absolutely right
crime is a crime and just because it's a
small amount doesn't mean that it
shouldn't go unpunished what what is
this extra paper stuff in your back you
should always carry a lot of paper they
get worried you have something they
don't know about this that's clever
this case is about attempt and you can't
prove attempt because he was arrested
before he got to the Statue of Liberty
at tempo lyric wires the defendants take
a substantial step toward the commission
of a crime he returned with a bomb then
why was the plan always to wait to
arrest him until he got to the crown
because that's what you thought you
needed to prove attempt there young
hungry they're smart let them fight it
out now the prosecutors are right you
can have an attempted crime with really
just minimal actions taken toward the
final act of the crime itself so taking
what he thought was a bomb to Liberty
Island would absolutely qualify as
attempted terrorism here
you know you're part of an important
tradition in my life what a trial
tomorrow going to trial tomorrow
what have years passed since his first
day be nervous it's the best bison trial
you nervous about the job
[Music]
[Applause]
how many trials have you done if you
clerked for the Supreme Court probably
zero and where is his team of other
lawyers - you're not gonna go to trial
which is one person on a terrorism case
in the Southern District of New York
please tell the jury what happened in
mourning well I saw this young man come
off ferry carrying a camera he was
sweating jittery I asked this use camera
and that's when I realized it was a bomb
a fake bomb made by the FBI I didn't
know that at the time were you aware at
the time that in addition to making fake
bombs the FBI had been recruiting mr.
Fayyad for 18 months no ma'am
she can't really ask those questions of
this witness this witness is a
precipitant witness to what happened
on the day that the defendant was
arrested so all of the stuff that
happened before he got there is totally
irrelevant for this witness he has no
personal knowledge of that and he can't
really opine or testify about those
pacifica facts this is the wrong witness
to ask those questions were you aware at
the time that in addition to making fake
bombs the FBI had been recruiting mr.
Fayyad for 18 months no ma'am
that he has no history of violence no
history of terrorist affiliation he
doesn't know that there's no evidence
indicating he's ever adjudged
interest in terrorism included by this
team of agents no ma'am
you remember mr. Fayyad well sir
yes hmm really how long have you worked
on that ferry 19 years 19 years and how
many ferries a day 25 26 thousands of
ferries tens of thousands of visitors
and you want the jury to believe that
you remember my client not just remember
him remember him well yes well unless
your memory has been jogged by the
government mr. Rock didn't have their
coz I quit my job because I am that's
how because that ferry he was on was the
last ferry I ever worked I was down
there on 9/11 ma'am
on the island right next to her the idea
that someone would one-up
[Music]
don't ask a question you don't know the
answer to on boss ask a question you
don't know the answer nice
okay closing argument we live in a
dangerous time I'm gonna assume he got
permission to enter the well to talk to
the jury our enemies used to be overseas
like seething tanks and airplanes they
wore uniforms oh that is not proper
argument here but now we're living on
the battlefield
I mean he's relying on things that are
outside of this trial you got to be
really careful when you make this kind
of argument and this kind of appeal to
emotion ah I don't think a prosecutor is
gonna get away with that it looks like
us they talk like us they live down the
hallway from us we only find out who
they are and the damage they want to do
after they've done it oh man they shot
up a nightclub that's not a marathon oh
come on man you can't bring in facts
from other terrorist acts as your
closing argument for this particular
criminal trial here that's that is not
proper at all this is a big gaff here
yes bail wants you to believe that our
government did this ask yourself how
much money how much time would it take
to convince you to blow the head off the
Statue of Liberty he's making some
contradictory arguments here that man is
not a criminal and law enforcement
prevented no crime here they
manufactured a crime instead of hunting
actual terrorists your government tried
to make a terrorist they contacted him
they befriended him it's really
unrealistic that these first-year
attorneys are going to be making the
closing arguments here this is a
high-profile case it would almost
certainly be their bosses or their
bosses bosses that are making these
arguments and handling this trial not
these really really young attorneys
regardless of the fact if they clerked
for the Supreme Court then just blow
reply they picked a target for him they
built a bomb for him
they made him yeah but he took the act a
totally separate Act I don't I don't
think that defense applies here I think
he has taken the predicate acts
regardless of whether the bomb worked or
not he thought it did so he had the
right mens rea I don't think the
entrapment defense works I don't think
they've really manufactured his
particular acts they may have helped him
along but I don't think that rises to
the defense of entrapment here it's easy
to become distracted in a case like this
to come emotional to focus on the wrong
things this case is about one thing and
one thing only it is about the power of
the United States government being used
to systematically target and manipulate
and incarcerate American citizens
because of their religion I mean there's
been no evidence of that no origin their
caller
I mean she's bringing in outside facts
too but what you have today is even more
powerful
you have the power to say no you have
the power to resist in this courthouse
in this courtroom in those seats today
you have the awesome power of Justice
and there's nothing more powerful than
that yeah yeah I think she's gonna win
States versus the Muhammad fire I think
he's guilty
we find the defendant Muhammad fired
guilty called it you guys do you mind if
I sit here
you
[Music]
jeez it somewhere goes you just want a
big trial I told you you were gonna lose
I told you this isn't TV okay what did I
get what you said on the first day get
something what did I get today you got
beat and now you gotta get up
and also you'll be able to appeal and
probably win and cause a new trial
because the prosecutor made ridiculous
arguments in his closing argument so you
know there's always that there's always
a feel the mother court
Darleen were these
yes I think so
worthy you just handled your own trial
as first chair you're so worthy okay now
it's time to give for the people a grade
for legal realism it was on the cusp of
being the most accurate show I've ever
seen but didn't quite make it it was
overly dramatic you had things happening
on a time scale that isn't really
believable but for the most part they
are making semi reasonable arguments the
things that are happening could actually
happen in real life it is far more
accurate than I ever thought it would be
so at the end of the day I'm going to
give for the people episode one an
a-minus a shockingly accurate legal
procedural from Shonda Rhimes I can't
believe it you know a lot of people
become lawyers because they think they
are bad at math and science if only
they'd learned the right way there would
be fewer lawyers in the world
that's why brilliant org created the
best interactive app for learning how to
problem solve from basic logic to high
school algebra to computer science
fundamentals brilliant turned learning
into a game
if only brilliant had been around when I
was a student I might not have gone into
law and actually done something good for
the world whether you're a student who
wants to get better math grades or a
parent who wants their kid to be a
scientist
brilliant can help you learn how get
better at stem and actually prevent
future lawyers if you visit brilliant
org slash legal eagle or click the link
in the description you can sign up for
free and learn all kinds of things not
related to being a lawyer and as a bonus
for legal eagles the first 200 people
will also get 20% off their annual
membership remember only you can stop
future lawyers and until next time I'll
see you in court